bienvenidos a resolviendo una cuadrática
por factorización vamos a empezar con
algunos problemas vamos a empezar con
una función fx igual a equis cuadrada
más 6x más 8 muy bien y en esta
presentación sólo voy a hacer la parte
mecánica de por qué de cómo resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones y por qué y
luego ya en otro vídeo voy a explicar
por qué funcionan esencialmente lo que
vamos a querer hacer es este
esta función cuadrática de este
polinomio cuadrática vamos a querer
igualarlo a 0 es decir vamos a tener x
cuadrada más 6x más 8 lo igualamos a 0
entonces esta ecuación como puedes darte
cuenta a lo mejor ya que racing intentar
resolverlo pero este término cuadra tico
complica todo el asunto así que lo que
vamos a hacer en este en este vídeo va a
ser factorizar déjenme ilustrar
esencialmente qué es lo que estamos
haciendo
déjenme pintó dos ejes no sé exactamente
como sea la gráfica de esta función fx
de hecho aquí está el eje fx y este es x
y lo que tenemos nosotros es una
parábola más o menos así entonces al
igualar a cero nosotros estamos
encontrando estos puntos de intersección
porque fx igual a cero sería lo mismo
que posicionarnos sobre este eje muy
bien entonces queremos encontrar cuando
fx es cero pues es justo la intersección
de la gráfica con nuestro eje muy bien
así que vamos al ahora así a ver la
parte mecánica de cómo resolver esto
esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer para
factorizar es decir que esta expresión
la vamos a expresar como x más algo por
x más algo esto es el proceso de
factorizar y eso debe ser igual a cero
entonces el problema va a ser encontrar
estos dos estos dos números que
me satisfacen que este producto sea
igual a esta expresión y te voy a decir
fácilmente cómo encontrarlo en los
números que voy a poner aquí deben ser
tales que al sumarlos me den 6 este
numerito deben ser sumados me debe dar 6
y multiplicados me deben dar 8 así que
vamos a analizar primero cuáles son
todos los factores de 8 los factores de
8 pues son 1 2 4 y 8 entonces puede uno
ir probando por ejemplo 1 por 808 pero
18 no son 6 vamos a ver qué pasa con 2
por 4 2 por 4 son 8 sí y 2 + 4 si son 6
así que aquí vamos a poner el 2 y aquí
vamos a poner el 4 entonces ya lo que
tenemos es una factorización y esto nos
sirve porque ahora tenemos dos números
que multiplicados me dan 0 entonces lo
que sí ya sabemos es que si dos números
me dan al multiplicar se me dan cero
alguno de ellos debe ser cero entonces
2 es igual a 0 o x 4 es igual a 0 muy
bien entonces lo que vamos a tener que
esto ya es muy sencillo de resolver
porque tenemos que x es igual a menos 2
verdad restamos 2 de ambos lados o bien
x es igual a menos 4 y esto ya es
bastante interesante porque tenemos que
de una ecuación obtuvimos dos soluciones
distintas cuando teníamos ecuaciones en
la variable o ecuaciones lineales o
ecuaciones de primer grado en solo
teníamos una respuesta aquí podemos
tener dos y eso se debe a que la gráfica
intersecta en dos puntos muy bien
entonces solo para que te des una idea
voy a sustituir este menos 2 en esta
expresión de arriba y verás que si nos
dé a cero entonces tenemos menos 2 al
cuadrado más seis veces x menos 2
+ 8 esto es igual a menos 2 al cuadrado
son 46 x menos 2 son menos 12 sumamos 8
y esto es 8 y 4 son 12 menos 12 si en
efecto es 0 entonces a ti te va a quedar
pendiente checar que también con menos 4
nos da 0 y entonces estos dos son las
soluciones del problema
e insisto esto es interesante el que
tengamos dos soluciones porque la
gráfica intersecta dos veces a nuestro
eje muy bien vamos a hacer otro otro
problema digamos ahora vamos a tener la
función fx igual y vamos a poner 2x
cuadrada más 20 x más 50 y otra vez lo
que vamos a intentar hacer es encontrar
las raíces o las soluciones de la
ecuación 2x cuadrada más 20 x más 50
igual a 0 y como puedes darte cuenta hay
algo esencialmente distinto a lo que
teníamos en el problema anterior y es
este
2 que antecede al al x cuadrada entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar o
más bien vamos a dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre 2 vamos a dividir todo
esto entre 2 y aquí también vamos a
dividir entre 2 entonces qué es lo que
tenemos si dividimos entre 2 esta suma
es sumar cada uno de ellos dividido
entre dos 2x cuadrada entre 2 es x
cuadrada 20 x entre 2 son 10 x 50 entre
2 son 25 y la ventaja que tenemos es que
0 entre 2 sigue siendo 0 y ya tenemos
una ecuación exactamente igual que la
que teníamos anteriormente verdad
entonces ya podemos hacer el mismo truco
que habíamos hecho decir que esto se
escribe como x más algo por x más algo y
que esto me da 0 ahora bien qué es lo
que necesitamos encontrar dos números
que sumados me den 10 y que
multiplicados me den 25
vamos a analizar los factores de 25 esto
es 15 y 25 son todos los factores
posibles de 25 y por ejemplo uno por 25
es 25 pero uno más 25 no son 10 así que
lo único que nos queda es 5 por 5 que es
25 y cinco más cinco es días así que ya
lo obtuvimos ya obtuvimos los dos
números que van aquí de hecho son
iguales para que este es un buen ejemplo
para que veas que no tienen que ser
necesariamente distintos podrían ser
iguales verdad así que de hecho ya que
tenemos esto pues el producto de dos
números que me da cero necesariamente
alguno tiene que ser cero es decir x más
cinco es igual a cero o equis déjenme
cambiar esta o para que se vea más que
se vea la diferencia de dos y ceros y
esto es x 5 igual a 0 y de hecho estas
dos ecuaciones son las mismas verdad y
la única solución que tenemos es x igual
a
y entonces tú me vas a decir oye pero tú
me de tú me había dicho que son dos
soluciones a estas ecuaciones
cuadráticas qué es lo que está pasando
aquí sólo obtuvimos una solución vamos a
ver qué es lo que ocurre en la gráfica
déjenme hacer esto un poquito más
derecho
muy bien más o menos digamos que aquí
está el -5 y está esta función tiene
forma de parábola y si sólo tengo una
solución quiere decir que por aquí viene
mi parábola le da un toquecito al eje y
luego se sigue subiendo entonces aquí
solo tuvimos una solución porque porque
toca tangencialmente a nuestro eje xy
para que veas que no te estoy enseñando
mal vamos a ver que x 5 x x + 5 es esta
expresión de arriba x 5 x x 5 es igual a
x que multiplica x 5 usando la propiedad
distributiva y luego 5 que multiplica a
x + 5 y entonces x x x es x cuadrada x x
5 son 5 x 5 x x son otras 5 x y luego 5
x 5 son 25 entonces si agrupamos estos
términos me queda x cuadrada más 10 x
25 vámonos con otro último ejemplo vamos
a tomarnos digamos x cuadrada menos x
menos 30 igual a cero entonces
nuevamente buscamos dos números que al
sumarlos medem me den menos 1 y que
multiplicados me den menos 30 vamos a
escribirlo estoy buscando números ahí ve
tal que al sumarlos me den menos 1 y al
multiplicarlos me den menos 30 y como
puedes darte cuenta aquí la cosa cambia
porque tenemos un signo menos así que
vamos a tomar vamos a ver todos los
factores de 30 que son 1 2 3
5 6 10 15 y por supuesto 30 entonces si
nos damos cuenta la multiplicación de
estos números deben ser de signos
opuestos porque si tienen el mismo signo
por ejemplo que sea más por más pues me
da más si es menos por menos también me
dan más así que necesito que sean de
signos opuestos y por otro lado deben
ser tales que la suma nos dé menos 1 muy
bien es un número negativo entonces por
ejemplo puede no tomar el 1 por 30 y
pues sí nos bueno ahí quizás deberíamos
ver los signos pero es muy fácil ver y
vas a ir agarrando práctica con esto que
si tenemos menos 6 y 5 entonces
obtenemos el resultado menos 6 por 5 son
menos 30 y menos seis más 5 son menos 1
entonces tenemos menos 6 más 5 de lo
cual podemos concluir que x debe ser
igual a 6 verdad si esto lo igualamos a
0 entonces x 60 o bien x es igual a 6 o
por otro lado x
50 de donde x es igual a menos 5 y estas
son mis dos soluciones yo sé que el
inicio puede parecer confuso pero
veremos más adelante porque es válido
este método y veremos más ejemplos
quizás ya esté es listísimo para
resolver otras ecuaciones cuadráticas y
también haré otros vídeos para que
tengas más ejercicios de práctica que te
diviertas